is it pronounced Caribbean or Caribbean
I didn't know jerk chicken was a part of
the Caribbean aspect also chicken
no Buffalo Wild Wings got some good
drink that is not Caribbean I know this
is not accurate but I think of tourists
and tiki drinks I am expecting just a
lot of beauty in my mouth a lot of good
stuff in my mouth
those like a crepe it's glistening in
oil looks like a burnt pancake I had
warm it's not bad but it's not that good
it is bad
no you taste is up there more color that
goes on your games like okay yeah I
guess so it is like from Barbados like
Rihanna like the more she sings it's
like okay
it looks like something you'd find in
the bottom of the ocean looks like
chicken pot pie
it looks yes it also comes with like a
pineapple taco reminds me a little bit
of like Indian just like the consistency
definitely not gonna lie this actually
blew my mind she's pretty good
it smells fried this looks like a
doughnut and I love doughnuts
when I first been into a high like this
pastry filling this would be like a good
sandwich
almost like yeah have you put something
in this this is a very dense ball though
I would eat this all the time Oh Briana
looks like Rihanna look like you might
like my food she likes meaty like whole
round things I feel like
oxtail this looks so delicious to me you
can make like played art like that this
kind of look like a Turk mmm mm-hmm
it has a nice little glaze on it it's
like sweet it's kinda like a pot roast
I like how tender it is oxtail
I love this this is great
it smells cinnamony oh that's not rice
that's coconut coconut I hate jello is
this jello it melts in your mouth
feels like I'm eating a Teletubby we're
gonna this one's not gonna do no passes
out of the concert they have interesting
textural things going on that's very
true everything is delicious I love it I
will go and visit you guys and eat all
of your food I'll definitely give back
at some of that oxtail and a constant
block day I'm pretty sure that's not how
you that we need to go on a trip to the
Caribbean as long as you're paying
Cheers
shout out to Rihanna shout out to all
the Caribbeans set out some Johnny Depp
and the Pirates of the Caribbean